foreign
.com exclusive
in live in studio this dude is in town
tonight man he is got a new mixtape
coming out actually Black Flag Black
Flag yeah we got MGK Machine Gun Kelly
in the building what's up man how was
everything been I know you're on this
the solo tour how's the tour life it
didn't come true man selling Avengers
with just me and my boys pretty cool
you've been uh doing a lot of I know I
saw on Instagram you were saying that
there were certain venues that you had
opened up for people yeah last year and
now we're doing them by yourself that's
what's up man that's the growth man yeah
um
yeah that was crazy man the whole the
whole like coming back to a place
headline like the coolest one was
probably Albuquerque
where I mean like you know like those
Southwestern markets are so difficult
they can be they are they can't look for
us for us anyway they were so
um the parking lot guy not the parking
lot like guards the backstage parking
lot yeah like we were walking from the
bus to the venue and he was like Hey man
would you I don't even remember me but I
told you last year when you were walking
out of the venue is that I said you were
going to be you were going to be
headlining this you were going to be big
one day and you know did you remember
the guy yeah and I did 100 because I
remember he stopped me okay he was like
he had like you know he didn't really
have like I forgot he just like messed
up teeth or something
he just had like kind of like this thing
where like just this like like a sign
like he was a sign from somebody so you
all just listen to those carefully and
he was just like that's you know you're
gonna be back here next year or not next
year but he was like you're gonna be
back here one day that's dope headlining
and he remembered when we came back and
he was just like dude you're so
inspiring to it was sweet man it was
cool let's talk about the Black Flag
mixtape of course a lot of people know
Black Flag is a punk band
um is there any inspiration do they have
any inspiration for the title they
didn't have any inspiration for the
title but obviously just use respect to
them right I mean I know they have like
a new project coming out soon I didn't
even I mean I did not know that
apparently hit the black side right back
but now let's talk about the project man
I mean soundly I know the um rage pack
was kind of like
um I think we I've talked to you about
this that was kind of the first project
I ever popped in from you and I was like
I was like you know I really wasn't
feeling it as much as the the stuff that
came out after that and stuff I heard
that came out before that so what's the
vibe of this new product it's weird
because I feel like rage pack was like
if I would have released it now it would
have been relevant because a lot of the
on the race pick I mixed a lot of like
Electro Dance music yeah which is and
dubstep Which is popular
pre-pre-popping so when I put it out
everyone was like uh before scrubs you
know what I'm saying so now you got ASAP
doing you know man I always like
everyone always hates it when I do it
and love it when somebody else who does
it so it's like the typical mvk story
Black Flag is just like uh
lifelike's a lot more live
instrumentation
probably the most confident I've ever
been in the project and uh you know we
opened up to do features and just just
way more universally what do you got on
the mixtape push of me
um whiz uh
French
killing Clan from a band called signal
Sirens
um [__] dude I don't know uh
that's what's up I want to ask you um
you just mentioned all the features like
I always wonder someone like you I feel
like kind of has taken a certain
approach to the industry and like you
know I guess not not really caring what
everybody thinks do you have any like
you I know you're real big on loyalty in
your Clique and you know you you travel
the country with the homies you grew up
with would you say you have any friends
in this business that you've met since
like that you would consider a friend
Ryan Sheckler Ryan shackler by Wiz
Khalifa walk up
inch it's a short list
I know I know French I heard some story
that likes there was something where
like French was going into a club and
you were outside and they would let you
in he's like I ain't going in that was
really cool man I forgot about that me
and Tech N9 were actually outside of
club and uh this is after the BT Cipher
okay so like
so here we are outside of greenhouse in
New York and uh
Ross Ross like or a friend of friends
out there speak French techno out there
like there's like French yeah you're
cool come in you know and it's like oh
yeah I got my guys
you know they're like they weren't on it
so Tech was like you know he pulled out
his credit card he was like you know
what I'll buy his table Yeah and all
that stuff you know I got us manure and
they still weren't on it you know we're
like what I mean uh French was like you
know what man I'm not going in there
unless unless my boys get in here and I
was like man it's really cool because
this is at the beginning of our
relationship right like it's cool man
this is pretty cool like he just had him
his whole Squad out there just waiting
and then like
Ross came walked in like 30 deep just
straight like straight straight in no
question nothing just third like and he
had so many people with him don't walk
straight in and uh I think honestly what
happened I think French just ended up to
wait now for us and I think we all just
ended up oh I know we did we went to we
left that we we didn't end up yeah
we went to Perfections I believe strip
club strip club we met up with Walker
there and me walking Tech N9 and French
and this is the first time like Walker
realized I was awkward at a strip club
so he put like two of the craziest girls
you know then they're like right above
my face eating each other's coach all
types of crazy stuff so that's amazing
yeah that was a fun that was that was
crazy I forgot the last time we talked I
was Tech not Tech N9ne was personal
friend as well of course yeah